près de saint nazaire la baule plus
belle plage d'europe
c'est ce qui se disait dans les années
mais aujourd'hui mieux vaut aimer le
béton et les balcons
comment trouvez-vous la baule maintenant
en 1979 babel c'est qu'elle a changé la
baule dans les années 50 et 60 c'était
le spot à la mode fréquentée par les
stars
les traditionnels vie la bauloise
attirer des touristes
beaucoup d'efforts ont été faits en
particulier par le syndicat d'initiative
pour l'accueil des touristes est
peut-être plus particulièrement encore
pour l'accueil des étrangers les
familles anglaises venait aussi attraper
des coups de soleil et se reposer dans
la fraîcheur des maisons de style anglo
normand à la fin des années 60 il est
toujours possible de prendre une chambre
dans des pépites d'architecturé comme
l'ermitage
mais au même moment un autre tourisme
explose
il faut accueillir une autre population
qui revendique elle aussi le droit
d'aller à la plage on change à ce mode
érigé à s'équiper à s'agrandir à devenir
plus accueillant une architecture dite
plus fonctionnel c'est en fait le début
de la bétonisation du littoral avec un
coup disons discutable en 1976 voici un
projet inspiré du mouvement des vagues
vu d'un mauvais oeil par une partie des
baulois que conteste-t-il la hauteur des
immeubles
la largeur du bâtiment en un mot
l'emprise au sol et tout ce qui peut à
leurs yeux abîmé le rivage de la mer
les bijoux d'architecturé bourgeoises
sont toujours là certains restés à
l'abri à l'arrière de la vie on aime
bien oui on aime bien quand même le
rapport aux horreurs du front demande si
ça voilà on trouve que le front de mer
mais mal à la baule a été saccagé mais
qu'importe la baule attire toujours
autant des vacanciers elle espère
atteindre les 100 millions de touristes
en 2020
[Musique]